[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is May
Martin one of the most wonderful
delightful engaging chats I've had in a
while they are talented uh delightful
insightful we already discussed we have
to do another one because there was so
much more to discuss but you'll see this
these two hours flew by I had something
I had to do afterwards I believe
otherwise I think this would have been a
three or four hour chat it was just so
much fun talking with May if you'd like
to see more of them check out uh sap
it's going to be out on March 28th May
Martin sap will be there uh stand up
special which will be on Netflix if
you'd like to see something right now
their incredible series feel good is
currently on Netflix we talk about that
a little bit in this episode but um any
chance you get I I think in May so may
for May Morton at my Largo go show if
you're going to be in the Los Angeles
area we're trying to get them to be on
the show I don't know if that's
confirmed but a nice way to work in a
plug for my monthly Largo show if you're
going to be in the LA area it's always
so fun if you want to come see me do
stand up go to
largo-la.com for tickets to that or if
you're not in the California Los Angeles
area go to peterhomes.com I'm currently
on tour thank you to everybody that came
out to San Diego it was so fun uh coming
up next is New Orleans Dallas Houston
Milwaukee Madison Royal Oak Michigan
Minneapolis New York New York and
Ridgefield Connecticut these shows are
going to be awesome they have been
awesome
and as always tickets will be always and
forever on petehomes.com if you like
this show the best thing you can do to
show some support we don't have a
patreon or anything like that it's just
try one of these Pete's picks why why do
I call the ads the pizza picks because
they're things I actually use and
actually love like the perfect Jean I am
obsessed with my perfect jeans in fact
it's gotten to the point where they're
the only pants I wear because they're
incredibly comfortable but they're also
incredibly stylish I've worn them to
premieres I've worn them around the
house I've fallen asleep with them
because they're not comfortable they're
almost PJ come I'm gonna say they are PJ
comfortable but they look incredible the
fit and the cut and the build of these
jeans is awesome but there's a little
stretchy secret to them stretchy secret
two percent spandex 2.5 RAM for x extra
comfort and movement that your man Parts
require I just flew here I'm recording
this intro in Toronto I always always
fly in my perfect jeans I always perform
in my perfect jeans I always do
everything in my perfect jeans because
when do I not want to be comfortable
when do I not want to look good and be
comfortable they're so soft you might
even forget you're wearing pants and I
haven't had to replace a single pair yet
I've been wearing them for years meaning
they are incredibly durable made with
super super high quality uh sewing
techniques and the materials themselves
are very very high quality they're my
favorite pants everybody wears pants you
want to show support support of the show
show yourself some support get some
perfect jeans the perfect Jane for the
Perfectly Imperfect men just 60 bucks
when you use code weirdo at checkout
liberate your lower limbs with the one
and only perfect Jean go to the perfect
jean.nyc that's the perfect j e a n dot
NYC news code weirdo at checkout for 25
off no fooling you ever see me on TV or
on stage or anywhere wearing jeans it's
the perfect Jean I absolutely love them
give them a try and show your support of
the show
also uh last Little Pete's pick here
this is my Apollo neuro the product that
has probably changed my life for the
better the most in the past few years
we've given away so many of these as
gifts uh and we absolutely swear by them
as a family both Val and I love our
Apollo neuro uh for those of you who
aren't watching the video I'm pointing
to this little device on the inside of
my wrist it looks like a watch it's not
a watch it is a wearable piece of tech
that helps your body recover from stress
basically it is a wearable hug for your
nervous system that uses touch therapy
to help you feel safe and in control
what does that mean it basically right
now it's on uh clear and focused which
is one of my favorite settings it's
using an almost sub-perceptual vibration
to speak to my nervous system in a
language of touch that it can understand
to help me Focus as I'm working I'm
doing a little work here I'm doing these
intros here so I want to be in a clear
and focused state so that is the setting
there's so many these settings but it's
like finding the fuse box to your
nervous system that Apollo can help with
it can help you relax can help you sleep
and help you focus and be more
productive worn on the wrist or the
ankle Bell wears hers on her ankle
Apollo neuro delivers gentle soothing
vibrations that train your nervous
system to recover and rebalance after
stress it is not a woo-woo or new age
thing it is developed by a
board-certified psychiatrist and a
neuroscientist both of whom have been
studying the impacts of chronic stress
in humans for nearly 15 years and the
more you use it the better it works this
is a chemical meaning it's not caffeine
free way of getting your energy up I
often use it when I'm driving if I ever
start feeling a little dozy when I'm
driving I just hit the buttons on my
neuro hit the energy setting and it
perks me right up Social and open
grateful parties great for the podcast
in fact as I'm talking with May in this
episode it's definitely on social and
open it's also a chemical free way of
loving yourself to sleep that absolutely
works not only does it work if I if
you're like me and you're in your 40s
and you get up to pee in the middle of
the night you can re-run that program
and it lulls you back to sleep which is
so so helpful to have something to quiet
your mind and ease your body back into
restful sleep just by something that
you're wearing absolutely incredible
Apollo's effects on stress sleep
cognitive performance and Recovery have
been proven in multiple clinical trials
and real world studies so again this is
not a crystal this is not uh something
that you'd buy in a lava lamp store this
is science and it's so wonderful that we
have it on our side to help us cope with
stress and you can get 10 off and show
your support of the show by going to
apollonuro.com weird that's APO llo
n-e-u-r-o.com slash weird show your body
some support show your nervous system
some support and show some support and
love for this show it means a lot
alright everybody hope to see you out on
the road I hope to see you at Largo
check out everything May has going on
they are incredible you will not regret
it
and in the meantime enjoy this chat I
hope you like it as much as I did
because I freaking friggin I loved it
get into it well yeah I saw that your
parents were we're just starting if
that's okay so oh sure yeah don't yeah
please oh thank you for understanding
the show
for real
it's what's it's been chilly and rainy
and it's like soup weather and it's cozy
weather and it's hot weather and I just
got a hat that fits me that hat fits you
perfectly
what do you mean
[Music]
I'm not really no that wasn't I was
happy to make you that wasn't like
I'm not person yeah
it works may I because you have short
hair yeah and you don't have an enormous
head thanks you have longer hair and I
have an enormous head so what are you
wearing what kind of like a toque I'm
gonna I'm gonna set what'd you say oh
that's I'm sorry what a two I guess
that's Canadian yeah two like t-o-q-u-e
two kids like a beanie Marion Pippin
Pippin yeah
excuse me I didn't know who I was
talking to yeah so Tuk also means it's
the last name of Pippin yeah from Lord
of the Rings
yeah but in Canada everybody was like
he's calling him a hat yeah well I don't
know what their reaction was
we can't project what can't all of
Canada reacted when Gandalf said full of
two people in the movie theater like
wait wait
Canadians famously very easy to confuse
yeah like wait and they stop they shut
down the movie I don't think he may hat
he Gandalf's wearing a pretty famous hat
yeah in fact may I oh sorry it didn't
mean a pun but may I but mother may I
mother may I
stupidest part of Lord of the Rings the
only part that doesn't age ganoff's hat
because it's so clearly one piece of
like foam yeah and it's like a wizard
it's a silly wizard silly yeah yeah his
robe at least it doesn't have stars and
Crescent Moon's on it I'm gonna say yeah
but the Hat there are a few scenes where
everything looks perfect yeah I'd say
this to Peter Jackson's [__] face
would you no I would not
thank you for all the entertainment but
the Hat doesn't look great in every shot
yeah that's it I watch them every
Christmas like can I please my whole
family okay you have the things we have
in common one yeah we're not big hat
people no to answer your question I
somebody just sent me
um a Nike
Flex fit what's that or maybe it's dry
it's like an athletic it's like a golf
hat I put it on I was like we found it
we found that that's how I feel this
yeah I got this yeah Alcatraz like it's
from Chicago
San Francisco San Francisco yeah yeah
yeah that would have been hilarious
there's some guy making a killing
telling Taurus that Navy Pier is
Alcatraz yeah people don't know this I
went to San Francisco with my dad and my
mom and my dad and I went down and we
did that boat trip around Alcatraz I
tried this on and I go in this is it no
I don't think you're allowed anymore oh
really I want to do like a seance and I
want to I'm into all that you love what
it what is it you love Nick Cage I love
like old prisons I guess is it decay in
general or just prisons like because I I
like old shutdown things I'm drawn to
like abandoned buildings yeah and I've
never had a supernatural experience and
I'm like I I'm I want it I really want
to and that's the place to go I think
facts facts facts yeah uh I believe it
was
someone who was in the movie The Longest
Yard which is shot at a prison yeah so
they did the Remake yeah um with Adam
Sandler and apparently that prison is
soups haunted really and yeah and and
The Story Goes May Morton this podcast
is already paying out yeah yeah I got
goosebumps it's not I just want to give
everyone a heads up not everybody loves
ghost stories it's not that kind of
story it's not going to trouble you oh I
won't be troubled I don't think you will
but I'm worried about our who knows who
these guys are yeah yeah
somebody who's like literally listening
to this podcast to get away from the
trauma of a recent ghost story
like a priest I don't know yeah poor
priests you know they gotta do so much
and also deal with the occasional like
the phone rings you're a priest Mike's
either a baptism or someone's life or an
exorcist yeah vaporexer vaporexer my
grandpa used to call them God botherers
he was like stop bothering God like he
was like let God be like this he didn't
like like organize religion I guess so
he was like a god bother her yeah he is
so good it reminds me of my friend will
Calhoun called actors word Pretenders
that's really good has a similar both of
those jokes have a similar level
condescending let's not forget Steve
Martin and your love of that vinyl but
I'm gonna finish this yeah I think I'm
going to tell you the other thing we
have in common other than our house oh
great okay yeah be a nice flourish great
and a way of welcoming you and making
you feel welcome
um okay so stay there was a skeptic on
the crew
and they were like they pooled the money
as unions and Crews and actors and
everybody agrees on one thing let's get
everyone to throw in 100 bucks every
film and TV show people love getting a
good bet going yeah so they pooled a lot
of money yeah and they said to this guy
if you spend the night in the prison
locked in a Cell oh my God you get all
the money and it was a couple Grand or
something yeah he did it and uh look I
wish I was the guy I could tell you the
whole story but all I heard was he took
the money but he wouldn't talk about it
he was so shaken by what had happened
that he refused to talk about it to this
day I don't know I'd love to get him on
I'm just kidding like that I get him on
that would be a boring guess to have one
great ghost story and then the rest of
it would be like I love gambling remakes
but yeah I'm scared I want to know what
happened me too yeah I also wouldn't do
it are you kidding me I would do it you
would do yeah but what's stopping me now
I'm like are you Brazen the money the
but like cash money cash money I think I
would do it you'd go in the in the cell
yeah I don't think I don't like the law
I've heard of them I don't like the lock
yeah yeah yeah yeah I want that open I
do a lot of Escape rooms you do like
escape room I do them like probably
every week well I have good news for you
what you're in an escape room right now
I vanished there's just a little
envelope with a tiny key yeah
are you good at them I'd spring into
action because I'd be like all of this
is yeah like deliberate yeah curated
there's a there's a pattern there's a
clue isn't that counting these that's
the pleasure you just helped me realize
yeah in a world of chaos what is this a
movie preview
World okay something makes sense an
escape room everything makes yeah and
it's linear you kind of yeah if you can
figure out what to do first just like oh
I gotta open this box and then it and
then you're like okay there's the key
now I have to find that so yeah I think
oh it's so soothing when I go I always
get the sense like I open like a like a
tea stained envelope yeah it's made to
look old and it always you can tell it's
been open three thousand times oh it's
crazy yeah it's worn down it's worn down
so it sort of takes me out of it yeah
that the old letter from the pirate yeah
it's clearly been
re-unrolled and re-rolled so many times
or you're like which part of this is the
button and it's just been like warm like
that too yeah well that becomes part of
the escape room is like there's wear
here yeah but then that's a valid I
agree you know a strategy it is a valid
strategy but I like when there's like
actors in them scaring me like I just
did one where a woman
chased me with a knife like a ghost
woman chasing something I'm gonna tell
you something I don't think that was an
escape I think you were just in a bad
neighborhood it's just in Korea Town in
an Alleyway yeah it was 3 A.M got a
little weird yeah I loved it she was
immersed tell me what you mean by what
you just said so
I went it was a date actually and I went
and learned all dates Escape rooms yes
yes very much it's good you see someone
under pressure in a crisis you see a lot
about them please
give you the firmest degree yeah they
there's a quote misattributed to Bill
Murray you just know he didn't say it
yeah before you marry somebody travel
with them right I think there is
something valid to that it's a little
Sinister in a room the woman with a
knife yeah well get a woman with a knife
in there may not work there yeah put a
clock on it because honestly everything
that I love about Val not everything but
so many things I love about my wife
would be revealed in an escape room and
now that we have a four-year-old I see
tension and I see that she diffuses it
with humor oh that's and with patience
you know what I mean yeah and frankly a
dinner is good too because if they're
rude to a waiter or if they're yeah
impatient or if they're intolerant of a
mistake yeah I'm like these are all the
things you're probably a wonderful
technical lover yeah yeah but like I'm
out like I can't technical lover I'm
sure you're in the future skills but
you're like a Porsche of a lover she's
like a German engineered lover but I
don't know I need someone that when they
bring bring out
the wrong side yeah that you roll with
it because life is a whole series of
mistaken sides yeah and sometimes you
just gotta go like you know what mac and
cheese worst things have happened yeah
but then I'm I'm like what do I want
like in a situation with a woman with a
knife like do I want to be protected do
I want to be the protector not that it's
one of the other but um I'm gonna say I
have no guess either yeah I don't I
wouldn't like it though so this woman
chased it was insane the best part is
you arrive and the woman working at the
front desk is just this sort of really
awkward kind of 21 year old with like an
asymmetrical haircut just being like
well uh the safety is a little and you
know she's gonna be dressed up later
chasing you with a knife because you
know there's
yes please you've got to go let's do it
like I just want to Delight in your
observation it's like when you go to a
comedy club yeah and there's some kid
ripping tickets there's a very good
chance if it's a certain kind of Club
he's yeah he's gonna do the middle spot
like he's gonna do the middle spot and
he's gonna have to
urgently and desperately reassess the um
the power dynamics yes yeah and earn
your and earn your respect like fast
it's not gonna work it's like pay no
attention to the like yes you you saw me
rip your ticket yeah that ain't me yeah
that ain't me and be a different guy it
doesn't matter yeah it doesn't work okay
so you see asymmetrical haircut you're
like you're gonna be in a wig later and
she's already pissed at us because we're
late or like our time has started so
Trey May and all I know Trey May
Bailey's running a little late to this
and look out look how everybody's having
a great time it just happens yeah I did
something earlier today 15 minutes late
really you're in a safe place okay cool
everything's cool so
um you do your safety things and I know
from reading the blurb online that
there's a live actor involved because
they got to tell you yeah in the 80s
they wouldn't tell you no no they tell
you yeah now because you could knock
them out or something like Panic the 80s
was insane
yeah yeah
everyone is
and it was dangerous and the live actor
was always Michael Douglas
in the game in the 80s yeah yeah it was
always Wall Street oh my God every movie
went to Michael Douglas in the 80s yeah
if we're remembering the 80s correctly
also he never played a poor person never
he was he has Rich face he's always in a
gray suit yeah Rich face Rich face by
the way Val pointed out to me some
people have glasses face it's one of the
funniest observations but even if they
don't have God that's what I'm saying
it's not funny if you see them with
glasses and go this person with a glass
of face but if you see someone who isn't
wearing glasses yeah and Val goes that
person has glasses I'm trying to figure
out if you have it right now I don't
yeah I appreciate it yeah uh I also
don't have smoker face I know you used
to smoke yeah I've started again I'm
having two per day two per day I look
forward to it all day and I gotta stop
you're doing the Sarah Silverman program
is that what she does yeah
I just realized it was an accident
um I think she's open about this that
she also isn't okay like a one or two
and she loves it yeah that's where I'm
at hey can I ask you something real
quick yeah have you tried the gum
Nicorette yeah uh no because I'm gonna
I'm not even trying to change you yeah
this is in fact a bubble of cocoon to
celebrate you and they're a sponsor yeah
and also nicorette.com
um nicotine is a wonderful chemical mood
elevator yeah appetite repressin
um brain stimuli it's a neurotropic it
helps you think which is why so many
writers like Mark Twain that cliche yeah
yeah you're not crazy for wanting your
cigarettes it's also incredibly
addictive
um and this is almost over and don't
worry everybody we're going to get back
to the escape room and we're going to
get back to the Steve Martin thing and
we're going to get back to the very good
thing we have in common yeah yeah the
thing we have in common is sort of the
compliment uh meaning just we're both
awesome we're both awesome and we both
wear one hat yeah and they're both black
yeah that my head is also black this is
Navy oh I'm colorblind are you really
facts oh yeah okay cool yeah so uh sorry
to be a little shape yes sorry just
kidding I'm just kidding I I really
can't see it though that's that's
exactly the the shade that I can it's
just on the edge yeah it's right there
you could also tell me that's a wine red
really yeah it's fun huh but isn't it
weird why do I know I'm wrong like I
know it's not yeah you told me it was I
could tell like the yellow uh gold dress
the white gold dress you saw wine red
you know what I saw when I looked at
that the movie Avatar the whole movie
played when I looked at that dress okay
real quick
um just my smoking friends the problem
is carbon monoxide this is almost over
and I'm not trying to save you no I want
to be saved nicotine is fantastic yeah
get nicotine remember the big tobacco
thing yeah they were like well
cigarettes are just a nicotine delivery
system yeah so nicotine itself is a is
benign it's like caffeine it's not
really the only thing that sucks about
it is that it's hugely addictive which
means if you go off of it you're going
to want to [__] burn down a building
yeah it's just a stimulant like a mild
stimulant it's a stimulant yeah and it's
control it's it's yeah it's crazy May
I'm saying crazy May meaning the world
is crazy yeah we want it to be more like
a escape room we want this to mean
something we want to count this yeah so
nicotine is a winnable game yeah you
feel a deficit you're feeling anxious or
you're feeling low yes this thing that
you can do that is going to reliably
elevate your heart rate
yeah no I think we have a lot in common
yeah very addictive personality yeah
yeah okay so this is happening right
yeah
the gum is [__] dope let me tell you
about the gum we're almost over I'm
gonna get it dude don't chew it like
you're are you chewing gum right now
what is this math class please what if
you hear me too nobody cares people love
it people love me hooray May Martin you
can put it right there on the table
what is this church I'm just hiding put
it there yeah
um don't chew it like gum okay chew it
once twice break it then put it up like
like snots it's like it's like you put
it in your it would have done still want
to smoke like you won't if you smoked
you'd vomit really it'll make you like
so into your blood that you'll be like
if you swear and if you did smoke yeah
no problem it's just more nicotine yeah
so I would say keep doing your one or
two a day but introduce the gum yeah
park it
and here's the the other sales pitcher
and they're not a sponsor I I don't know
why we're I'm taking this much time
because honestly it's a big thing
smoking is a big thing yeah yeah and I
quit for 10 years and and uh yeah I
don't know it's just in the pandemic
like I get I get it well
look more on that yeah let's Circle back
but to close the thing is you can do it
anywhere you could be doing it right now
I shot an entire pilot I used to choose
Lodge I imagine because that's what
Marlon Brando was doing in The Godfather
he just had wads of Nicorette here and
just like tons of negotiations you think
his energy would have been higher yeah
that's true
he really was something you'd have to
prod him with an electric charge every
once in a while
we're still making fun of that poor man
but anyway try that two I the the
cigarette itself is this other
psychological tie it's this Beacon that
you burn that says no one tells me what
to do and I'm alone yeah it's this like
get away from me but also I want to be
attracted to other people yeah also see
death everywhere yeah see abandon
everywhere yeah you're sort of smiling
it yeah yeah yeah you know it and
there's the oral fixation like there's
you know and it's excuse to go outside I
get all of it I'm in a writer's room
right now I'm doing for and so you know
yeah plug it yeah she's two uh no um a
new show a new show yeah but it's nice
to you do like simultaneous shirts no I
only did I did two seasons of one show
and that's done oh forgive and forget I
didn't know it was done did you want it
to keep going yeah yeah I've been to be
honest in every interview I've been like
no you know we really wanted to leave it
where it was but uh just yeah this is
the real one of course like if we Bond
over Alcatraz I wanted one more season
but I think we did leave it it's the
British like there's short Seasons like
six episodes yeah no one would know yeah
it would be like oh it was a British it
was a mini series yeah yeah yeah exactly
the office the most famous British show
and it's perfect and it is perfect but
also you do a Christmas special I would
do that but also it's like it's all
about a couple and you'd have to just
have them keep breaking up and you know
what I mean you'd have to just torture
them forever look I was sitting right
there when I found out that HBO's
Crashers it's called crash hand called
Crashers for fun was canceled and it and
I don't know why I'm saying it like it's
a tour over here where Katie is but and
it actually was a relief because what we
had done three seasons but yeah so I I
feel you both ways yeah there's a relief
to it
and I get we could have done a fourth as
well but yeah he started very quickly
going like it's okay because it's what's
happening yeah and you don't want the
characters to start behaving out of
character you know what I mean well in
our case yeah season four my character
would have started to succeed and I was
like the show's called crashing not
flourishing yes yeah it was just about
to start doing well yeah it's like
that's not the show the whole show was
supposed to be like most comedians this
is the backdrop for my talk show yeah
don't get a talk show that would have
been season four yeah and then it's it's
a different show Even though there's
crashing involved in that my The
Writer's room I'm doing is on the lot
where they filmed the Larry Sanders show
no yeah
I'm geeking out do you love it so is
this a new may show it's uh teen
Thriller I mean they have in Greenland
they just greenlit the writers room so
it's like a teen Thriller sort of comedy
uh and I'm just a supporting character
but yeah I'm into it but you're you're
involved in the writing yeah it's my
yeah it's like I'm show running Vision
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's your show yeah
okay so and they have a writer's room
for the pilot no done the pilot we're
gonna write all the scripts yeah so it's
like this sounds very good to me it's
the longest I I don't think I've ever
been Monday to Friday in a office like
since I was about 24 or something yeah
because in England we just wrote in my
it's just me and my friend wrote both
seasons and this is like the first time
I've been you and Steven Merchant I
understand yeah yeah I'm in my friends
yeah that's how all shows in England get
written you get Stephen merch you either
have Ricky or Stephen yeah and you just
Stephen of course I understand
this is very interesting to me because
yeah because again doing crashing being
in a writer's room I was like what this
is weird like it's so weird to me it's
like a nine to five but it's
sometimes if that's bad then it's worse
if that's good then it's better but yeah
like sometimes it's eight to seven yeah
it depends on what you want to do it's
super fun but I'm not used to um I mean
I'm used to being like you know I feel
like a teenager yawning in the corner
and like looking at the thing so I'm
trying to inspire confidence
oh I would immediately hire someone else
to run it I'm kosho running with um with
an amazing guy who think God has like an
attention span yeah okay yeah yeah
because my this is bad advice
potentially but my style was uh did you
watch Mad Men yeah was Don Draper I was
like I need to be able to leave yeah
yeah I want to leave yeah Judah Miller
who ran our room was was our steady
Eddie yeah who had an attention span who
like kept things going that's great but
I was really like I'll be here from you
know this isn't always true but I'd like
to be there from like nine to two and
then I'm like I gotta go yeah uh and
you know I I wouldn't I wouldn't say
that's for everybody but that worked for
me so maybe you can start unloading
those afternoon hours because if you
control freak though oh really yeah yeah
but what are they gonna do yeah
I'm just now I'm like they're gonna
watch this yeah yeah I wanted Inspire
confidence what's that I want to inspire
confidence so badly but the other day I
did go I have a really important call
guys sorry I'll be right back and then I
went in my office and um wrote well no I
I like to list every country in the
world to soothe myself and and so on
Sparkle that website you can so I
memorized Oracle Sparkle is like there's
thousands of quizzes so it could be like
movie posters or trivia and just
quizzing you to like alleviate anxiety
it's just like yeah I memorized 197
countries in the pandemic and so then in
order I do it in a weird I start in the
South Pacific and then I go up spatial
yeah it's spatial yeah and okay but I
just find if I haven't done it in the
day I feel a little out of sort I gotta
do it I understand but it was funny that
they all thought I was having a call and
I was like Fiji Kiribati like it's very
obsessive but well it was it is it it's
compulsive as well I mean there's a
compulsion to do
I'm trying to make you not feel othered
yes I have compulsive Behavior as well
for sure everyone has compulsive
Behavior it's not making sense of things
it's like okay that the feeling when I
do the 197th one and it's like you know
a little like animated uh thing goes off
yeah I'm like great okay it's an escape
room it's an escape room but here look
you again this isn't old man homsy gives
Mae Martin advice but there there are
two very weird hats that you're wearing
right now
I'm sorry three yeah a Chicago Alcatraz
hat that you got with your dad
but I think you can either create this
show which I'm assuming the pilot you
wrote in a fever of when inspiration
yeah and feeding yourself creatively
feeding yourself socially feeding
yourself psychologically physically all
these things were lining up and it
spills out of you and then and now
you're trying to recreate that energy
yeah so inspired May yes so let's
picture inspire me there you are you
have the the Young Einstein haircut from
the 80s like you're like writing with a
quill in my mind yeah yes exactly you're
Joseph finds in Shakespeare and why
hasn't he been in more movies Joseph
finds I don't understand really good
question but there must be a reason
there's got to be a reason you know what
I mean I mean it's not his performance
there's always a reason there's always a
reason don't dig too deep on the Joseph
fines
but every time I think about him anyway
two you're trying to keep people
inspired which basically is a job that I
would argue other people can do uh yeah
yeah and I'm trying to convey that
original feeling and the tone that and
the reason that I'm excited about it
yeah right yeah that's exhausting yeah
trying to get other people as excited
about your project as you are is really
dumb yeah and a waste of energy my
co-show Runner is amazing and having
yeah because that was the same with my
other show I had my my best friend Joe
was so just having another person who
cares about it as much as you is really
helpful or like you had that woman
Judah Miller was wonderful he and he
really kept things running sorry I
thought Judah was Jude like Judy Judy
yeah yeah yeah Judy Miller Judy Miller
Judy Miller we also well I don't I don't
want to bore people it's interesting I
do want to leave you just with one
kernel which is like the way you do it
is the right way and you don't need to
be in charge of other people's interior
States you can't be in charge of other
people's interior States and the
writer's room is a tool for you to use
when you say what it what I'm a control
freak so I can't leave whatever they do
is just for you to yes or no Jon Stewart
would say The Writers come up with
things that inspire you to write the
thing they don't write the show they
come they generate ideas for you you
look at them you use your instinct and
your gut and your vision I would say
your job is not to install your vision
into other computers yeah you just hold
on to it and maintain it and if that
means taking a nap or going on a walk or
doing your country thing like yeah
another thing Conan said he was like
your job is to be in a creative and good
Flow State that's your job it's not to
motivate troops you think I couldn't you
could hire me to motivate your troops
and I don't know anything about your
show yeah that's true you know what I
mean so anything you can Outsource
Outsource that's really true and and
also they are all really
really smart and that's already
happening we're there yeah
um but it is weird like having I was in
London for 12 years so there's like a
whole language I don't know and uh just
the lingo of writer's rooms and that
whole process I have like imposter
syndrome but oh okay but things like get
out of here like breaking a story I'm
like that just means figuring out the
story right it's figuring out this yeah
you know what I was like 15 terms and
you're done right okay yeah yeah that's
the one to beat yeah there you go shut
up you're like that's why sorry this
this is something that's close to my
heart is is helping comedians go from
being waiters to restaurant owners you
know what I mean and and it seems so
daunting but I'm like really just be a
waiter like keep being a waiter and just
know that there's a staff there that's
there to help you yeah they're there to
help you and if and if the best use of
your time is to leave and write the
script and then come back and kick it
around with them there's no wrong way to
eat a Reese's like you don't have to be
in the room by the way maybe there's
someone watching that's like don't tell
people this because ours was an HBO show
Judd was there it was different we kind
of felt like we could do whatever we
wanted into a set as long as Judd was
happy yeah but I I think he would agree
with me it's like you're trying to
paint a dream
and it's your dream it's nice and the
writers are there too The Colors Of The
Wind yeah they're the Colors of the Wind
and one of them's Pocahontas yeah and
one of them is Mulan because it's one of
those yeah
yeah
we both knew it was Pocahontas okay just
because people might not care about uh
show business as much as me but I do
think we're actually talking about
self-love green lighting your own
process and that applies to every aspect
of life confidence imposter syndrome
yeah yeah I have that a lot and also my
instinct is to go self-deprecating so
like especially in England like just to
go in like well obviously I'm a piece of
[__] and everything I say is stupid
right it feels like of course that's
what I'm a wanker in a bell I'm a wanker
and a bell please you can use the terms
I'm just kidding but you'd go to
self-deprecating yeah and here that
seems like not the thing to do like
there's a culture of like yeah I'm I got
this it's faking it like fake it and
look like confident and all that stuff
yeah that's why I like Don Draper I know
he's a fictional character and I know
he's a monster in a lot of respects but
one of the things he did right was he he
would nap in his office or he would
smoke a cig I know I'm trying to get you
off cigarettes I just admitted delicious
he'd smoke a toasted Lucky Strike yeah I
am watched Mad Men with my grandmother
in England that she was this old British
woman yes passed away now but we watched
this together and we were watching um
there's like sex scenes in it yeah and
uh so I think there's a scene where
they're having sex she's on top of a
laundry like a washing machine that's
going like this yeah and they're they're
boning and I'm like oh my God what this
is so awkward and then it cuts to the
next scene and my grandma goes did she
make it like did she come basically my
grandma wanted to know if she make it
did she make it yeah isn't that wild I
was like I don't know they didn't show
that part but I hope so let's watch it
again with closed captions yeah it says
sound of completion your grandmother can
rest easy totally I don't think Don
Draper was making a lot of women come
though I I think it was all about him
uh the 50s as a huge fan okay tell me
yeah because I I don't remember I'm
gonna give you show based evidences yeah
yeah okay yeah yeah
[Laughter]
first of all as a concept you're
completely right for men in that time
yeah yeah and everything that he
represents had the show been a little
bit more honest it is a soap opera and
it is a um fantasy yeah meaning the
fantasy extends so far that not only is
he a narcissist
but he's also making women come which is
which is insane no you're right no
narcissist nihilist it's also like did
you make it yeah
going for it but there's the the scene
where he gets really mad at
um I believe her name is Dick Dicky
Barrett's wife so Bobby Barrett so yeah
so Bobby Barrett says I want the full
Don Draper treatment he's like what does
that mean and he's like women talk about
you so it's such a
it's hot I was ready to be like that's
disgusting no no I want the Don Trevor
treatment that's so hot everyone's Dead
come on yeah somebody that there's lore
about yeah you're in line you're in line
for that ride imagine yeah imagine being
like that having a reputation yeah a
sensual reputation yeah
hope I have that I mean how would you
ever know well well and he gets really
mad at her he actually leaves oh he ties
her to the bedpost so wait for real yeah
and then he walks out and oh wait the
fantasy's ruined I know because he's
he's a narcissist at I mean he has
narcissistic Tendencies I don't know if
he has the full disorder but it seems
like he might I'm remembering this now
and he it's because his name means
everything to him right so like he
doesn't want people talking about him
the whole thing is secrecy don't get me
started of course gotten me started
because he also wants to be considered a
good husband yeah and and not a
philanderer yeah so he represents the
cognitive dissonance that all of us have
yeah and deepen our identity yeah like
you're a monster and you're an angel
like both of these things are happening
our shadow selves or Shadows apparently
we're supposed to not be at war with our
shadows we're supposed to embrace it and
and look it in the eye and yes because
the more friction there is the the more
kind of splintering right that's exactly
right and you're the first guest to
bring up Shadows before I did yeah but I
knew you would we'll get back to the
compliment and we'll get back to the
escape room but that does seem to be
part of your show and your word and just
so you feel safe mine too like I love
looking at the what is
I don't even like the word broken let's
say interesting or complicated yeah and
in conflict and in Conflict yeah or
well just nuanced in any way and yeah
yeah and the way the when we were
talking about nicotine
uh substances have those things too like
I I I won't project onto you I'll say
for me yeah what was appealing about
things like alcohol and to a lesser
extent drugs was the guaranteed
experience of it yeah everything seemed
so so sometimes I mean calling swamp
Freud but I'd say this to my mother and
it would upset her and then I'd say this
is a very similar thing to my mother and
it would make her happy yeah I'm over
here going like what is reality and then
you're like you drink this and it makes
you drunk yeah I was like I like this
[__] well do you know what I'm like
Gabor mate
he's this writer and and well he was a
doctor I think I used his face cream
yeah yeah yes and I love your yes hand
yes
I loved it you know um but he says
you've got a first if you're
investigating why you're an addict is
like well what is it giving me first you
look at the pluses and like it's giving
you something huge like yeah whatever
that is
yeah yes sense of whatever for me yeah
what was it for you I guess like being
present uh boot like booze I think Coke
was my thing that made you more oh my
God it was like brought you into your
experience yeah it was like there was
suddenly four walls around me for the
first time like I just felt like uh yeah
and confident I was a you know awkward
Weirdo And
um I just was talking to somebody about
the Vanity Fair party which is kind of
like a famous
um party yeah I can't believe that
exists they're a famous party first yeah
of parties yeah I'm sure Johnny ham was
at this party and I went for some reason
one year it had to be a promo thing and
I went to the Vanity Fair party and I
really didn't enjoy it and I'm not
saying that to be oh I'm so special and
I'm too spiritual for that I just was
overwhelmed it was a very basic thing I
was like what do I do here yeah who do I
talk to and I talked to somebody I won't
say who it was but he he's in recovery
and he was like yeah those parties are
fun if you're on cocaine yeah
by the way I'm not saying anyone to do
cocaine but I I do look around and I'm
like why are these people yeah some
people are just rocking it really and I
think they're on cocaine looking back I
think they're like because if you're on
cocaine and Taylor Swift walks by that's
a fun time oh you're like hey yeah hey
how you doing yeah
you're like Taylor Swift is going to be
really excited to talk to me yeah
exactly yeah yeah exactly you're Michael
Douglas in the 80s and you're you're at
the Vanity Fair party in the 80s he's
welcome anytime and we don't probably
I'm sure right yeah come on Basic
Instinct must have been just apparently
on the set of Star Wars they were all
blown now I don't know what the links
are worse for me but also they're coked
up I just read because they didn't know
it was going to be ahead so they're just
doing this terrible sci-fi movie so of
course they're just sucking it down yeah
yeah all right you're The Wookie yeah
we're really getting through the day
except Mark Hamill I believe Mark Hamill
was not invited to the cocaine party
good he's a pure Angel yeah his
lightsaber is green for a reason [__]
yes
also did you know I'm a big Survivor
fanatic and I just was reading because
I'm the new season starts this week
season 44. oh I can't wait um wow but I
didn't know in the Obama season yeah
yeah yeah yeah that was a weird I can't
believe you got it I like that a lot
yeah which means next season's Trump
season oh sorry it'll be real intense
yeah
um it they found on a previous season
washed up on the beach a kilo of cocaine
they were in like I in like Venezuela or
something please can you tell me the
truth right now that's the truth I'm
gonna send you the article I believe you
I just can't believe you and actually
you know what this ties in with what we
were saying because there was a
contestant called Shane who's the only
contestant I've ever seen who was in
nicotine withdrawal because I always
wonder like he was a Chainsmokers whole
life and then he's there on the beach
what they do on the island he's losing
his mind and uh he was open about it
he'd have these big outbursts like
heroin like
yeah anyway yeah it's a cliche but
people coming back from Vietnam said it
was harder to quit nicotine than it was
to quit heroin but you can't go to the
corner store and buy heroin although
that's true you kind of could you can go
to the park I suppose but like it's much
easier Yeah by by cigarettes I think it
makes you crazy yeah so and then on so
Shane's freaking out and then he's
walking down the beach and there was a
kilo of coke and he please he ran and
hid it uh in the forest were the cameras
on him at that moment no but then the
producers found out and they and no one
had done any apparently but they they
took the they took it away but he was
like I should have done it before the
challenges the writers are like we're
gonna safe keep this for you and then
the next challenge is like okay you have
to water ski down yeah yeah dude seven
flips it's got to be seven flaps yeah
did you guys find my uh package
again as somebody who's dealt with
addiction
the feeling that's that's filled a
metaphor for me yeah meaning I know
exactly how this man felt yeah in
withdrawal
from a stimulant yeah so nicotine
finding a secret in fact like a brick
doesn't that just speak to something for
me it does this the secretness the
secret friend
I don't want to awaken the werewolf in
you no no I really I just want to
concede that I want to be sensitive and
if this is uh inciting in any way
uh sorry no no I was a weird flare-up I
just want yeah I just want to make sure
we're both cool uh the secret thing
about like I'm gonna bury this in the
woods and No One's Gonna Know totally
right a control thing and I mean even
just acquiring and then having drugs
like in a little thing and all the
paraphernalia and like it's very weird
and it's another Escape it's an escape
room wait I should tell you about the
woman with the knife yeah you may okay
okay this
so I go to the escape room the the
awkward girl is there I know she's gonna
it's not like they've hired another
actor yeah budget for that and um we so
we know she's going to appear at any
point and at one point uh it's like in
an apartment and there's a shower
running in the bathroom is really high
production value we can hear the shower
running we can hear a woman being like
in the shower she's in the shower yeah
and we're like [__] and we know we have
to go in there and get a key while she's
in the shower and and uh can I ask seven
questions yeah yeah yeah is she naked
that's I was really just one we never
saw her naked the implication was but
she was a ghost dead she's a dead person
yeah so you don't want to see Dead
boobies no maybe you do well do you
remember that movie
um seven ghosts or something or 13
Ghosts or 13 Ghosts there was a hot one
oh a hot ghost yeah well I would argue
that the ghosts that Jack Nicholson sees
in the bathtub in The Shining it's one
of the most haunting yeah yeah yeah
because she deteriorates in his arm yeah
like that's I think about The Shining so
often yeah like it's the whole movie is
just so deep in my I agree yeah he's in
room two 237 yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
obsessed are you obsessed yeah yeah get
out of here
and anytime I'm in any hotel Corridor
and like the just the the quiet the sort
of humming electricity and the carpets
and I'm I get like a little nervous
facts can I just say I I've never
thought this before we sort of feel like
hotels like I'm a hotel yeah and
everything that was happening in that
hotel is happening I mean that makes me
sound insane but I have a basement
filled with the memories of slaughtering
Native Americans
interesting yeah my and and I have
elevators filled with blood from what we
eat to the leather of our shoes like
there's all this repression yeah of the
consequences of living in Duality which
is someone wins means someone loses yeah
and I mean that kind of without
exception yeah like it's obviously with
war and stuff but even micro
transactions social transactions even
stand-up comedy I killed or I died
everything and we repress all of that
violence I'm using violence very
liberally but I mean yeah violence
against ourselves too against ourselves
and also like the the fact that
like the pressure of being loved and
loving you're very close people and you
know what I mean and it's I got you
right away you can't she wants to love
his sister
yeah and provide for them and yes it's
it can yeah I think it but he's broken
some like claustrophobia of like I can't
yeah and then because there's too much
[__] in the basement yes there's too
much [__] in the basement there's too
many uh Native American burial grounds
yeah there's all American no play makes
like he said and then you add the burden
of support and yeah work and and the and
the myth that he had to do that right
Parenthood and yeah and and is the son a
stepchild oh that's interesting I think
it might be a stepchild I think that
adds to his discomfort yeah that's good
or right I'm just saying he's he can't
find himself in his life yeah he's
literally in a labyrinth and he
literally freezes and that's us I think
that's why see this is why I knew we
would get along there's there's people
that like relate yeah there's some
people you go like don't you feel like
the Overlook Hotel yeah and they're like
no
I'm sorry
blood child I'm trying to say it that's
interesting
yeah yeah no right it's not his
stepchild okay can I just say he seemed
like a stepdad yeah because he was sort
of disconnected yeah yes oh my God but
he wants he he wants to be good yeah
237. what else did you have something
because I'm gonna take you back to the
shower oh uh no I just love it and
um oh I was gonna say not everyone
relates that's it being the Overlook
Hotel yeah or do you relate to the
feeling of Jack I relate to the one the
woman I project my mom onto that yeah
woman too hard and I put myself onto
that boy yeah like again I feel like
having two Greek gods yeah your parents
and my parents didn't get along oh
really yeah he's like being snowed in a
weird hotel for what 18 years I'm not
saying my childhood was not The Shining
yeah but there's a feeling of lack of
control which again brings us a little
bit back to addiction it's like of
course you're looking for
stand-up comedy is also a control freaks
Delight yeah if you're good at it like
if you get to a good place and also just
all teenagers want something private
that's their own right you feel like you
have no control over your life and so
yeah Mulaney talked about he had a bit
about like under his bed he had a uh
like a cigar box that had like a
Cosmopolitan magazine and three
cigarettes yeah there's something about
that's the cocaine on the Survivor yeah
yeah yeah secret when I quit drinking I
saw the hormone monster from Big Mouth
yeah literally like I I wasn't
hallucinating but the way that I saw it
was like a friend that was like yeah you
don't want to remember me I'd meet you
on those weird Road gigs oh completely
watch it die it was really hard for me I
guess you have to find a way to tap into
that like sort of
tortured artist ego like but healthily
and be like I can have that private
space and and make it for myself and but
wait tell me what you mean by that well
it's like our because my dad was a
writer and I would was always like how
do you I don't know how do you have kids
and be a right I don't know because you
have to go
to a different place in your mind like a
sort of egoic solo place and he was like
you just learned to kind of just close
the door and yeah
um go go there yeah yeah I I as we were
walking in I told you we moved out of
the city and that helps I do my set then
I drive home yeah that's not that I used
to come home and bring in the energy but
a little bit like roasting everyone yeah
come home and be like hey Leela what do
you afford yeah but like
I've said this a million but houses have
thresholds because you're supposed to
drop
it's a transition space yeah yeah you're
supposed to put your briefcase down if
you're Don Draper yeah take your jacket
off it's to signify we are now leaving
the battlefield of work yeah we're
coming into a domestic area take your
[__] shoes off yeah where I can
soften we need to decide yeah yeah so I
use the ride to soften that's not you
relate to that do you listen to music
and all of it yeah anything anything I
can do something that has nothing to do
with me is very yeah or comedy or comedy
in general yeah I don't really even
watch I watched murder and stuff let I
mean yeah you know I get it yeah yeah
and you go to the Survivor and I go to
escape rooms and I I want to talk about
your love of Survivor but let's finish
there's a woman in the shower who you
don't see naked with the seven ghosts
and Shining there are hot ghosts let's
be real yeah and and all they said to us
we are there definitely are um yeah yeah
all they said to us was they she can't
touch the actors can't touch you again
in the 80s we didn't have that though
they're gonna touch it yeah oh my God
horrific horrific Michael Douglas is
cold hand come
um I can hear his voice me too
it's like nasal isn't it yeah nasal and
there's a there's like it's like
Elizabeth who's on the phone or
something yes but it had a cascading
gravel too yeah yeah
Ant-Man yeah man I was like maybe say no
you know he he said he got throat cancer
from going down on Catherine Zeta Jones
Kenny Ling that's a wild thing to say in
the Press also can we please
why yeah why not just say you smoke
cigars we know you do we've seen you do
it we've heard your voice yeah yeah
you're smoking [__] yeah also of all the
things that can give you throat cancer
liquor can give you throat cancer you
immediately throw your wife's
can you imagine her reading that
interview and being like really because
yeah look
yeah you blame the vagina you're gonna
blame the vagina do you think I'm
picturing him coming home from the
doctor's appointment and yeah throwing
his brief his 80s briefcase down he's
like you had to go to second base yeah
always with the
yikes but that was a meeting like Publix
is like all riffs I think publicists
were like how do we get ahead of this
how do we make it hot this diagnosis
and make you look like a badass I guess
he wasn't in that meeting Catherine's
either yeah oh my God she was not
consulted
I mean it's insane I guess you can get
let's not talk about it whenever people
are like you can get HPV in the back of
your throat I'm always like you could
also just not mention that never
mentioned never talk about it and I just
did it okay so there's a a woman in a
running shower yeah and so we get we go
in and get the key and there's no jump
scare and then this dead woman comes out
of the shower and she kind of can't see
us at this point like she's because
she's a ghost so we're cowering in the
corner and she goes to her bed and lies
down but there's a key around her neck
that we need to nugget and she's
pretending to be asleep and I know when
I go up there she's gonna wake up and
freak the [__] out seven sloth oh my God
yeah yeah seven slot Seven slots really
trying to help you hear those periods
seven plus and seven is in italics so
you know it's a movie yeah I can see it
so clearly we all knew the sloth guy was
gonna jump oh my God I still hated every
second of it that's very Mary iron John
uh I'm not going to tell the whole story
because I love telling the story of iron
John iron John is a story is a myth
about masculinity and William Blake
wrote a book called iron John anyway
suffice it to say iron John represents
um wildness okay and uh there he gets
caged this wild beast man but he's a
wise Beast okay so he's he's red and
hairy
um just like Esau I'm just putting that
together Jacob and Esau his brother was
wild and hairy so he locks him the king
locks him in a cage but then the the
prince loses a ball into the cage of
iron John and iron John and the ball
represents innocence because if you
think about it like a pregnant belly is
a ball you lose our innocence around the
age that the boy the ball goes in yeah
so the the iron John says uh you need to
free me and I'll give you your innocence
bag he says the ball back yeah where's
the key under your mother's pillow your
mother does not dream it's the space of
her dreams and she does not dream of
having a wild man for a son she dreams
of respectable things doctors lawyers
does this make sense Sheriff yeah like
something uh nice yeah pretty wait is is
iron John saying this iron John's no no
this is analysis interpretation okay
yeah yeah it's William Blake's analysis
okay he's like the pillow is under your
the key is under your mother's pillow
yeah it's also where your parents make
love so you have to go in and so throw
it in the whole thing so Freudian yeah
but I love that it's under your mom's
pillow and you on I feel like I did this
I feel like I stole the key of my
mother's dream that I would be a pastor
yeah I would be her sweet Golden Boy the
rest of my years I she doesn't know but
I stole it from her bedroom on blocked
my own wild man yeah it doesn't mean
bad man no but you're it's your power
yeah yeah it's also not gender specific
it's this energy that we all have which
is like I'm gonna and it's actually
through embracing Shadow yeah to
embracing wildness
um decisiveness and all of these
wonderful things that returns you to
your innocence it's not going and
sleeping between your mom and dad it's
not time for that it's time to steal the
key and free the wild man it's crazy I
like that and also the more you repress
it the more it's gonna burst out with
violence yeah that's right you try to
put it in the cage yeah well the first
thing the king did that was right was he
caught it and then he put in the
courtyard of the Kingdom that's actually
the first step of health is you go I
have a wild man yeah you let everyone
say guys yeah this is my wild man you
don't put it in the basement like the
shiny yeah you put it in the courtyard
nothing good happens in a basement
everybody yeah
okay let's go to the mid-rolls and then
we're gonna get to what happened when
you took that key oh I mean don't don't
even say it
I can literally uh 120 seconds okay
sweet
weirdos this episode is brought To Us by
a very new Pete's pick this is the first
mention of lmnt I'm saying it slowly
it's called element because I heard
about it from Dr huberman I was watching
a YouTube video of his talking about
hydration and he kept talking about an
important part of his morning routine
was putting element in his water to make
sure he was getting hydrated getting
that boost of energy and of course you
know I'm super interested in everything
that can help cognitive performance so
he kept saying I put element in my water
but uh I couldn't find it when I
searched it it's because it's lmnt it's
spelled l the letter L M and T and it is
electrolytes and pretty much nothing
else meaning no sugar no carbs nothing
nasty or artificial but it tastes
incredible and what does it do it helps
you hydrate because healthy hydration
isn't just about drinking water it's
about drinking water plus electrolytes
so this has become a huge and wonderful
part of my morning routine I look
forward to it it tastes fantastic gets
me feeling ready to face my day also
it's wonderful after as I just did I
just worked out and to replace that
sodium and that water that I lost during
the workout both I get myself another
element I absolutely love it it's also
just a sidebar sometimes at night I'll
be craving food I'll be craving
something I just want to eat and I'll
have an element instead and it's a
wonderful way to make that I do
intermittent fasting make a fast more
sustainable and easier to do because
you're giving your body some of those
calorie-free things that it is craving
so you're giving it that support so I am
super super excited like all the pizza
picks I found them first I started using
them and then I reached out to see if
they wanted to give you guys a promo
code and support the show so basically
that's what's happening this makes sense
you lose water and sodium When you sweat
both need to be replaced to prevent
muscle headaches and energy energy dips
as I said taking this in the morning
gives me a great boost of energy but
most people are only replacing water why
well because since like 1942 we've been
told to drink eight glasses of water per
day whether you're thirsty or not but
new research tells us that drinking
Beyond thirst is a bad idea it dilutes
blood electrolyte levels especially
sodium which leads to those headaches
and that low energy cramps confusion or
even worse it can be quite dangerous
this low sodium situation is super
common among endurance athletes and that
solution isn't the solution isn't to
just drink more water it's to drink
water and electrolytes how do we do that
enter drink lmnt element just mix this
flavorful electrolyte mix into your
water bottle and you're good to go no
sugar or artificial junk just
electrolytes and great taste I always
get dehydrated on planes as well so I've
been taking this when I fly and it's
super wonderful I don't have to pee
three million times because I'm not
drinking more water than I need but I am
absolutely satiated because I'm ticking
both boxes lmnt has your electrolyte
needs covered former research biochemist
Rob wolf and keto keto keto games oh
keto games excuse me keto games founder
Tyler Cartwright and Luis via Senor
formulated lmnt to provide the optimal
ratios of sodium potassium and magnesium
for health performance and energy they
also formulated element I'm going to
start saying element now because I think
that's I think that's how you're
supposed to say it to please your palate
try orange salt Citrus salt or
experiment with five other flavors like
my favorite which is watermelon salt
which is a classic flavor combo an
element
so happy they're working with us they
came up with a fantastic offer for us
for weirdos go to drink
lmnt.com weird and use promo code weird
to uh you basically get a free I want to
make sure I'm getting this right you get
a free sample pack that includes one of
every flavor when you make any purchase
through the link this is the perfect
offer for anyone who's interested in
trying all the flavors or wants to
introduce a friend to element they have
a no questions asked refund on all
orders you don't even have to send it
back so you could get the refund and
still try it this offer may be claimed
for any first time or returning element
customers and it's exclusively available
through VIP element Partners you won't
find this offer publicly available so go
to drink
lmnt.com weird and use promo code weird
for your free sample pack and get this
trust me get this into your morning
routine it makes a huge huge difference
in my energy levels in my mood my brain
functions my workouts everything I just
love having this bio hack to getting
better hydration without having to drink
nine gallons of water necessarily I
still drink a lot of water I just make
sure I'm getting enough electrolytes
with it so give it a try and get into it
I'm also as you can tell I'm not at home
I'm on the road I'm in Toronto as I
mentioned and of course I have my
element with me I've got my perfect
jeans over there I'm wearing my Apollo
these are all the things I travel with
and this one here is my next Evo
Naturals this is their stress CBD
complex it is a hemp extract and
ashwagandha which is an adaptogen that
helps your body naturally recover and
cope with stress the new year is a fresh
opportunity to achieve your full
potential but you can't do that you
can't be here best if you're stressed so
get ahead of stress this year by
experiencing the full potential of CBD
with next Evo Naturals I we've talked
about a lot of these different CBD
Brands here but the difference with next
Evo is they have completely cracked the
code and it gets into your blood so much
faster than other brands certainly than
other tinctures these are gummies right
here only next Evo uses smart sorb CBD
proven to be 30 times better absorption
in in the first 30 minutes so don't just
use any CBD most CBD products on the
markets you only have two to ten percent
absorption so 90 at least 90 percent is
wasted and if you don't notice it and if
you don't feel it and if it's not
getting absorbed you're not going to
notice it and you're not going to feel
it you're probably going to say CBD CBD
just doesn't work for me next Evo is
here to completely change all that it
delivers four times better overall CBD
absorption and has been proven in
multiple clinical studies so when I talk
to people that say I don't know why you
like CBD it doesn't work for me it's
probably because you're not absorbing it
and you don't get your dose right
because you don't know uh when you feel
it you're not seeing any results this
absolutely changes that and when you
blend it with the ashwagandha that helps
you with stress that helps you with
trouble sleeping and gets into your
blood so much faster they really really
figured something out with these gummies
so make CBD a part of reaching your full
potential with next Evo Naturals go to
next evo.com
podcast and use promo code weird to get
20 20 off your first order of 40 or more
that's 20 off 40 or more at
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com slash podcast with
promo code weird show your body the
support it needs and show this podcast
some love and support as well alright
everybody let's get back into the second
half of my chat with May Martin
okay okay
I'm dragging it out but there's no real
resolution except obviously she wakes up
screaming can no no no lying dead on the
bed hold on who goes I'll tell you
what's a good story yeah you go yeah I
go yeah how was that decided uh that's a
really good point yeah I think uh I was
trying to impress her I think it was a
date I forgot it was a date so I think I
was like I'm gonna I'm gonna go
but you wanted to be brave I wanted to
be brave of course you wanted to show
them your ambition and I'd also been
like no I do a lot of Escape rooms like
that was Michael Douglas now I do a lot
of this game yeah and uh but then very
quickly the tables turned because she
wakes up screaming the the dead woman
with the key so we run we have to we
know there's like a salt Circle that if
we're in that Circle we're safe
um yeah very the way do you know the
Witcher the witch I know oh The Witcher
there's oh that series it's a serious
Henry Cavill he puts these rings of
stuff that will trap a witch inside of
it or a spirit or something I would do
it in a in a pinch like yeah yeah in a
panic why not try try it you have salt
yeah and here's a wedge yeah
and if it doesn't work now you're just
being murdered by a witch in a salty
Circle yeah which is humiliated
um at least you go out seasoned yeah
exactly yeah
okay so a tiny before you get to the
Salt yeah you can touch them yeah yeah
you can get the key in Balance yeah they
warn you like that please don't punch
the actors or like attack them in any
way right and also what's so weird is I
know it's that awkward girl from the
front but you just forget because she's
in a full match mask and like like
rubber mask yeah and and long and black
wig and classic ghost paraphernal
they're going the ring on it they're
going pure ring yeah but sort of she's
singing in the shower which I feel like
the girl from The Ring would not do
unless it was like a haunting Japanese
yeah a folk song like yeah yeah yeah is
there anything scarier any child song oh
yeah slowed down
no right I just wanted to try it Three
Blind Mice
it's all yeah yeah I hate it I went I
was with my daughter and we went into
no I wasn't with Leela I was a Val and
we were in New Mexico and we went to
this like Heritage Museum so really like
PG yeah g even this whole museum but it
was a celebration of Japanese
folk Horror oh and there was this dark
section it was just all black and there
was a door and I was like I'm gonna do
it get out of here I opened the door and
in the first room there's a little black
and white TV playing the ring just
playing like the worst parts of the Ring
oh my God and there's a warning that
says uh warning there are live actors
there's jump scares like by going
there's strobe effects if you have a
heart condition and I was like I'm
getting the [__] out of here get out
this is a small Museum where they've
just I mean this is act one of a horror
story like oh my God Pete died he went
into a yeah Heritage Museum in New
Mexico and didn't turn away after there
was a warning mud room he was trying to
impress his family he was trying to
impress myself and I failed yeah no you
did the right thing I think I did that
yeah yeah I appreciate it so you could
touch the cold skin of this um naked no
she's not naked you've made her naked
but she's in like a rope that I made her
naked you said she was in the shower she
came out dressed in like a white robe
and uh I don't like that I know and so
we run we get in the circle so we're
like okay we're safe and then strobe
lights she comes in and now she has a
huge knife and she's like slashing at us
like just so close to us and then I
became full like coward like I just
closed my eyes waited for it to be over
like it was curling into this person
like oh you grabbed them oh I grabbed so
success I was like shielding like using
them as a shield I did a full force
measure like like just throwing them out
of the way like it was a real moral I
said Sinbad because in the special afros
and bell bottoms he talks about being
chased by Dracula and tripping the woman
he's with so that's what you did yeah
you just immediately that's you know
Brett Goldstein yeah yeah so we went to
and say what's up with you and Brett
Goldstone oh yeah you're all about it I
love Brad Goldstein by the way good
choice what a babe we went to um my joke
Halloween Horror Night sorry no
I'm sorry who's the guest of this
episode
I'll say up until this point unclear
you did what now we went to Universal
Studios Halloween Horror Nights and it
was like foreign yeah and in a group and
and we went through and the Texas
Chainsaw person came running at us and
he grabbed Brett grabbed me and threw me
at them and screamed Mavis which is what
he calls me he goes Mavis and just like
I it I could afterwards you like Chum
yeah just to block this serial killer
yeah we had so much to unpack after it
was like we we got through the thing and
then I just we're finally out and I just
like turned to him and was like what
happened like what did he say he was
just like I I panicked like he's like
look Ross can't would have saved you
yeah yeah yeah but bread gold
right in the path of the danger and I
really thought because he's big and
strong that I'd be hiding behind him and
yeah no it's the strong guys with the
great bods that are like I worked really
hard on this yeah I don't want anyone
let somebody right cut off my picks yeah
which is Brett's fake voice that's his
real voice is more like oh really hard
on can I say thank you can I say thank
you because Val loves Brett yeah it's
just this assumption that like
she loves him and we all know it yeah
and I'm okay with it right I say good
choice good but the way that I slightly
tease Brady G knowing full full well
that he'll probably see this is that I
go like Holly oi foul it's me just
kidding it's me Brett oh my God it's
always like it's real voice he's a
comedian's voice yeah and then he does
like a very Michael douglasy sexy normal
human's voice and then he's yeah and
then he has this you can go there it's
very
sexy yeah you're mad fat yeah that was
good no it was all right yeah it was
really good I love it and then he's like
oh I love Muppets Christmas I can't do
his real voice
um okay so you're cuddling with your
person that's the end of the story
really basically yeah are you still with
this person no but not for that reason
not because it wasn't like we got out
and we were just the trauma was too too
much that's enough of that yeah that is
enough of that but it is I do take I do
a lot of like First Dates at Escape
rooms and I sort of thought that was
normal and it is a big ask like to
terrify someone well I don't think
you're going to what I would call an
escape room you're going to like
immersive horror experiences yeah yeah
those are an escape rooms
yeah Sherlock's misplaces oxygen yeah
yeah I don't know I think he's doing
hail oxygen well uh he solved creams
um very interesting love it need it um
let's get to some of the questions
because I can't believe we're was
practically done yeah what was
um what do we have in common you love
when shows are canceled love when shows
are canceled I just like I heard you say
that on tig's podcast yeah and
immediately I was like this is one of my
people oh you like a live show like yeah
oh I'd always prefer if it I I was going
to say that I rehearse this in my mind I
don't know often but I was like
I mean how great would it be if one of
us canceled this we're loving this can
you imagine yeah the joy if you were
like I can't I got code oh my God I know
if I was like may I can't you would be
like oh man and you didn't even have to
be the one that canceled it yeah and
then oh well just shoot me some dates
that's the best getting to be the one
who's like that's okay don't worry about
it you have to be cool about it I love
it I knew I knew that now it's never
felt compelled to be on stage every
night and once I'm there I love it like
more than anything but I would always
rather be I don't trust I don't trust
the people that go up fearlessly and
constantly yeah these are the people
that get off after a bad set and after a
good set and they seem the same yeah I'm
very like that's the audience I'm great
yeah I'm deeply affected by what
happened yeah so if it's canceled I will
not be affected yeah I I can just remain
yeah and it's like a big adrenaline
Spike and then like it's good to have a
break from huge yeah huge okay speaking
of yeah walking away from Stand Up
Seymour so you love that is that's let's
get small right I believe yeah yeah so
there's one comedy recording crazy guy
and I love that they're all great
they're all great except the Steve
Martin Brothers it wasn't I don't know
that one no one knows yeah
side a is you know what I loved the
Martin Short Steve Martin special on
Netflix I haven't seen it it's really
great it's just like silly and charming
and um warm and you know okay we're
gonna watch it yeah and it's sort of
that kind of Comedy that just will never
age because it's just um because it's
Martin Short yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah
I Val and I have been laughing lately
that Martin Short's first special which
I haven't seen I don't know if it exists
but the title of it was I Martin Short
goes to Hollywood that's so good which
is just
he'd be on my top five people to to hang
out with I've never met him but yeah
yeah I met him
um a couple times but both times I was
like let's not ruin this right yeah yeah
I was like I just you don't need to meet
me yeah I have everything to lose
meeting you not that he's a turd I don't
think he's a turd I think he's a delight
yeah and very funny I don't want to push
it yeah yeah I don't want to push it I
don't want to meet Bette Midler because
she's too important to me I mean it's
the same for you yeah with me and Martin
yeah yeah yeah I don't have that for
Bette Midler I'd be excited to meet
Bette Midler but as I'd be talking to
her I'd be like beaches like I wouldn't
know okay okay I would be like no
encyclopedic but I I think I'm sure
she'd be amazing but focused what are we
loving Steel Magnolias Hocus Pocus
beaches no beaches is her Steel
Magnolias yes yeah and then you got like
Ruthless People and all these it's sort
of crazy 80s
is that what she's like David Bowie to
me I don't know why we're all you know
what I mean oh wow I believe that some
people have good reasons yeah but to me
it's just let's dance and I'm like
really we all love let's dance like it's
you gotta go I gotta get into Midler
yeah yeah I have a middling appreciation
event I have a t-shirt that has a
picture of Bette Midler and David Bowie
at a dinner party
I think is there waiter Tom waiter Tom
waiter yeah Tom waitser yeah
um so you love Betty meds and Steve
Martin I can relate with you on Steve
Martin so you said your parents were
hippie-ish yeah they were like uh real
comedy fans and um very open about like
very Progressive about sex and sexuality
and stuff what does that mean like
they've talked to they never assumed
that maybe I'd call it a special hug
they were like yeah they were like I put
my penis in your mouth yeah literally
they're like it wasn't like the stork
and you know and then my tummy what if
you're like there's a Cabbage Patch in
the back where I [__] your mom
I straight up bugged her yeah and it was
awesome it was awesome she loved it I
loved it there's no shame no shame a lot
of nudity in the house a lot of nudity
in the house yeah can I ask was that
okay yeah because I have a daughter and
I've had some I've had some comedian
friends be like don't let your daughter
see you naked and I've been sort of like
but isn't that sort of a weird [__] I
think I think that's that's what we're
going with yeah she seems okay with it
like eating everybody's just kind of
there'll be a natural point where it's
stops happening but like yeah yeah I'm
talking about I'm coming out of the
shower and she's coming in the bathroom
like it's and I don't want to be like my
nudity like I understand why maybe it
would do that but I don't want to
stigmatize it came from your penis yeah
she was with me first yeah exactly yeah
50 of me yeah no is it who knows she was
in a muffin that I ate yeah and then she
was in my crumb yeah
and she was in mom and now she's here
very crazy not wild so you would see
your parents naked a lot yeah they were
yeah they were they were just I think I
sort of exaggerated what hippies they
were but yeah they were definitely super
oh yeah yeah
to make it in the business yeah yeah you
know you gotta say your parents were
happy Tail as old as time yeah Martin
Short my parents are happy yeah Mae
Martin my parents are happy like my dad
was in a band uh in the 70s called
Johnny eagle and the evil smelling
stinks show and he was Johnny eagle and
uh so they were just weirdos you know
they were cool and they loved like my my
and the evil smelling stink show yeah it
was like a sort of
I guess this is around python era and
you know what I mean so it's funny yeah
he's hilarious I mean that would work
now I think the eagle Johnny Eagle
Johnny Eagle smelling stink show and we
had this framed photograph of him in
like a sequin jacket over his shoulder
like being Johnny yeah
can I just say
nudity philosophies will vary but
silliness
especially Dad yeah for me moms all for
it but dads can be like they're they're
like can be hulking yes they're the
biggest way to connect I think if they
struggle to connect in other ways yeah
yeah and it's also this I I was thinking
about this like anthropologically and I
know we're getting into kind of like
gender normative talk but men are often
bigger so when on a date what is the
what virtue is a man often in a classic
ham and cheese sandwich date
the guy is trying to show that he has a
sense of humor meaning like isn't that
like a way of saying like I have a lot
of testosterone but I'm safe yeah yeah
right yeah maybe yeah I don't know
yeah I put it to you is that true yeah
yeah yeah
you did follow my dad on Instagram
because he just got on Instagram and he
started at this stage in his life
becoming a puppet maker he started
making puppets get your dad on this yes
what is happening he's the pastor he's a
puppet maker he started making these
bizarre sort of Haunting puppets out of
and he cuts off his own hair and he
glues it to them yeah and this Japanese
folk order yeah yeah it's very if they
came alive we'd all be [__] it's yeah
you gotta you gotta follow him I will at
the James chatto c-h-a-t-t-o c-h-a-t-t-o
yeah he also does pizza based pun work
where he's photoshopped the pizza based
pun world yeah what does that mean like
he'll Photoshop an image from well like
Lord of the Rings uh like pie of Sauron
you know what I mean like and he'll
Photoshop like a pizza pie like yeah
yeah oh my God now I just want to find
another one end of the gray
Legolas Lego I can't do it it does sort
of obscure a life of pie he did yeah
yeah yeah okay that was right there yeah
yeah [__] all right well I'll come up
with a brilliant one later you don't
always have to win people yeah I'm
talking myself out loud okay so you have
these groovy naked parents and they
loved comedy and they did they teach you
introduce you to Stevie Martz yeah
Stevie Martz did you have a special tie
to him because your last name is Martin
where you're like thanks son I mean you
had to have yeah probably when you're 10
years
I think I'm Harry Potter and this is
what if I met him and I was like Martin
like
um and Martin Short and Martin Short
but then also Kids in the Hall was they
they my mom also silly to me yes so
silly and my mom took me to see them
um I guess it would have been like a
reunion tour in the late 90s and they
were like rock stars in Canada and
people were and they were all in Drag
and it was just like weren't they like
very so queer sexually queer Progressive
yeah like imagine it was like the early
90s and they're like making out yeah
yeah only one of them's gay but they it
was awesome I think
yeah I'm trying to remember that they
would do a lot of like sexual sketches a
lot of there was a sketch where like uh
one they're in a sauna but one of the
guys just has breasts right remember
that like just like always like playing
with like what are we doing they're they
would play female characters but not in
like a Monty Python like right way like
they just play really great female
characters that were like really sexy
and like like they're yeah I just it
blew my mind I was like a 12 year old
yeah yes and they're so they're so funny
so that was shaping you and your parents
appreciated comedy yeah I like to
obviously unpack where my parents might
have like I called them Greek gods that
were fighting yeah and I'll also say
they put out the comics for me and they
took the sibo Cosby crisis they did
that's nice yeah and it really
changed my life yeah yeah I was probably
like nine yeah just young enough to be
like my dad put on a jacket to watch a
man tell jokes it's crazy and yeah I
feel grateful that I knew at a young age
that was like a viable thing you could
do in the world right that was cool well
you started I I I'm sorry I'm sorry that
you talk about this I was starting to
say sure you talk about this and I'm
sorry so I'm sorry that you talk about
this all the time but you started when
you were 13. yeah at Second City I
started taking improv classes and then
doing shows soon after that I don't this
must have been like just the wild west
before anyone cared about having like
children and yeah there's some weird
girl yeah like in my school uniform like
smoking in the club like I'd go on stage
smoking yes like it was so surreal yeah
but and then really quickly it was like
yeah three or four nights a week I was
doing it really no I dropped off my
school when I was 15. say what I dropped
out of school to do it yeah I was 15. I
say this with full respect you're like a
carny you're like a born died in the
wool like I'm a performer I don't need
history I'm out of here I don't know why
though because like I said like I love
when shows are canceled I wasn't like
that then uh I'm pretty introverted like
I don't know what I'm introverted too
yeah but there was I again I can't say
what it was for you but I felt like
there I felt like a rocket on a
launching pad yeah and there was a real
desire and it wasn't again my home life
wasn't that horrible yeah but it wasn't
horrible at all
um
but there was like a
there was a a beacon calling to me and I
was like I I know I have to make myself
uncomfortable to go into Boston I I was
doing shows when I was you know 17 18
where some of my earlier shows yeah and
just hooked and I was like this is it I
gotta do this I didn't really start
properly until I was 22 but like I got
the hook in me but the you know it was a
it was a
I want to be comfortable but I knew my
true Comfort would come when I
yeah picked up the sword and went into
the woods yeah I knew I had to do it so
you had that too yeah you had to let
your Beast Boy out here yeah exactly I
got on his shoulders and let him and
that's what stand-up comedy was because
it was like all these wild Pirates like
weird not all of them were great yeah
and a lot of them not just saying this a
lot of them were on cocaine like a lot
of people were like look I'm already an
alcoholic I'm already a drug addict yeah
and this seems to be something you can
do with that lifestyle same but you
would meet like I remember seeing Gary
Goldman when I was that age and I was
like oh my God so there's a way to do
this and Ellen was one of those people
and Ray Romano was one of those people
in Seinfeld and to be like celebrated
for being weird and different and
instead yeah yeah it was yeah oh it was
the coolest Club to be part of like yeah
yeah go ahead lately no you saw you're
very intuitive you saw me waiting to say
something go on oh no yeah I got it yeah
you got nothing not really but yeah yeah
I loved it okay okay so I heard you say
a couple things on tiggs podcast
and I was going to throw them back in
your face and embarrass them right no no
but you did I remember you said that you
were basically doing a Bill Hicks
impression oh as a teenager yeah yeah
for a while and I one thing I it's
actually not throwback in your face you
were like she said which was an
interesting question she was like what
advice would you give yourself and you
were like don't do impressions of other
Comedians and I was like we all do that
I just wanted to alleviate but that's
nice to hear you you know what I mean I
want to be like that's what you do for
the first 10 years yeah you're just
doing it again Brian Regan I'm doing
yeah Seinfeld I'm doing all these guys
so I wanted you to feel safe too like
you're just trying on different
personalities as if there's an original
choice there's seven billion of us you
know I mean there's gonna be a few
repeats yeah there's a great Bill Burr
bit where he goes we already have that
guy you see a guy in the street you go
we already got that one like that's a
repeat yeah so I was curious you're 13
you're smoking in your school uniform
and you're doing a Bill Hicks for those
who don't know Bill Hicks is very like
uh political and like and uh aggressive
you know he's like attacking the status
quo what were you do you remember any of
your bits when you started
I mean I think I was doing a Bill Hicks
impersonation off stage mainly like in
in the club like uh but also tough guy
yeah yeah I definitely remember talking
about the apocalypse a lot and being uh
on stage like I remember doing a show I
would have loved to see your little set
list apocalypse
at the end of days yeah and I talked
about school I guess and
I remember being booed it was like what
because it was a New Year's Eve show and
I just said I I rightfully booed like I
I uh people had paid for their tickets
they were all dressed up and I was just
probably high and had a cigarette you're
not you weren't supposed to really smoke
on stage yeah and uh yeah I was an
[__] and people were like Boo
absolutely boo I'm not a rightfully
booed is your second book right between
food yeah because you were really
you were just skating too close to the
end I don't know why I was so angry it's
like I just it it was just a moment of
like it hadn't dawned on me that oh yeah
this is actually for them all I'm
hearing is you figured out in front of
people what every child needs to figure
out you know what I'm saying yeah like
yeah it was a normal thing like you
realize at a certain point that not
everyone is taken with every little
thing you do yeah and that there's a
certain amount of responsibility and
preparation required aren't you glad
that like YouTube wasn't like that
there's no record of this thought right
out of my brain I think about this all
the time oh my God
we'd be ruined like the things I said
like the yeah terrible comedy oh my God
I uh I kind of wish I could see I wish I
would post it now yeah because I'd like
to not that I'm like the Sterling
example of how great a comedian can be
although in my own taste I am I like my
own comedy yeah but when I when I was
starting it was like I remember I had a
joke about
I'm just gonna say it you'll hear the
Seinfeld yeah I go food court
what is this where Rebel foods go on
trial here's the tag you're gonna fry
for what you did chicken that's good no
it's not you're kind you're kind do you
have a video of that somewhere I wish
that's literally before like if you
filmed your set back then you had like a
Sylvania VH like nobody had that there's
a video on YouTube of me in like it was
like a televised competition and I did a
character and it it was 2003 but it
looks like it's from 1980 it's like
grainy Canadian television like it
really it makes it looks like it's so
old but it's yeah I thought you were
about to be like and it doesn't age well
the character is let's just say
white and very uh very offensive um uh
let me see let me see I had something
and then I got I got so caught in don't
make that riff offensive
and I got stuck
um what were we
and Bill Hicks and your bits and the
apocalypse and you got booed
when when did like something because I'm
interested in helping people and and
sobriety is something we talk a lot
about yeah we don't have time to go into
the whole story but you started at what
age were you doing uh American cocaine
is that something you don't want to
share you don't have to share that no no
I I mean I I think it like right at
puberty I I kind of like 13 I started
not Coke but like just smoking weed all
the time and
cigarettes and just like anything I get
my hands on and then and then probably
uh 15 I was started dating like a 27
year old comic uh who uh did a lot of
coke and then uh
when that ended I was like well I missed
the gun and then I found the coke
elsewhere but none of my friends you
were like boy I miss Coke yeah you're
like you thought you missed the person
but you were like it turns out it was
the cocaine 100 this is the Survivor
cocaine yeah can I ask a this is helping
me because I'm realizing that I have a
bias towards people that are addicts and
that end up doing drugs because I was
going to be like but your parents seems
so loving but clearly that's not how it
works like was there um
and I'm assuming you've done some work
on this was there a deficit like an
internal deficit was was there something
you were trying to fix with these things
or was it really as simple as I dated a
coke dealer and I wanted to have fun no
it definitely was never about having fun
like yeah it was never fun you know what
I mean
yeah like yeah don't get me started we
watch the way that drugs and alcohol are
portrayed in movies and TV I'm like
that's not it it's either one or the
other it's either Leaving Las Vegas or
it's like yeah we're finally on spring
break and we get to just live it up and
I'm like it's it's definitely had some
great times but then it very quickly
becomes just like a horrible shame cycle
and yeah it doesn't work yeah it doesn't
work long term yeah we're definitely not
the yeah I know what I'm hearing there
is is
somebody in my family quit drinking and
what they did was they they labeled it
evil which again it's using an addictive
type brain yeah to quit an addiction
yeah an addictive brain is black and
white that's why I like I believe it's
in the program it's good until it's not
or it works until it stops yeah and I I
appreciate the subtlety that you're
giving it going like when I look at my
time drinking yeah there were these
incredible drunks that I had I remember
getting very drunk by myself I was Often
by myself uh watching Clay Aiken win uh
American Idol or whatever yeah I was in
Euphoria really I was sitting there
going like I wish I had video of it
because I was only like 23. yeah and I'm
sitting in my kitchen in Chicago
watching them on a laptop and I'm just
like you get them clay because he was
such like a underdog he really was and I
was like full of thousands of tequila
and just being like you get them and
then my my first wife comes home and I'm
like pretending to not be drunk I'm sure
it was all that I haven't thought about
clay yeah in a long time I think about
them every day yeah they play every day
driving back from your gig yeah
um that's how I that's my threshold I
bet he has a podcast he must can I just
say everyone does he must every previous
contestant we were just talking about
this yeah I I was seeing sometimes I get
the Press breaks on who's making the
rounds and and this is no disrespect but
I saw a mini driver is promoting
something and I was like I wonder if
many drivers go to podcast Minnie Driver
has a podcast are you serious any
questions many questions she has seven
many questions to her guess I'm like
this is a thing man like actors have
figured out that it's a great thing to
do in between jobs yeah but as a you
know I feel like the first kid that did
ham right out of reactor I want to have
some Heroes who are enigmatic to me like
I don't need the war yeah the mystery
imagine if Marilyn Monroe had Twitter
like she wouldn't have any of the lore
so I'm in the Village Lantern which is a
club in the West Village and I forget
who it was and I if I could remember it
but it was an open mic yeah and they
were just kind of speaking from their
heart it seemed and they were like all
this [__] we have to do as comedians can
you imagine getting a Facebook invite
that said Richard Pryor invites you to
this Open Mic show like like yeah you're
talking about YouTube but even like the
The Growing Pains of Life yeah Richard
Pryor or George Carlin had to get three
friends to come to the show so you could
try it yeah yeah at a steakhouse
it didn't right yeah but it was it was
weirder and worse it's like they went up
in between burlesque acts right right
like a weird truck stop
houses exactly gay bathhouse a bath
house yeah at least nobody saw it yeah
which is the motto of the bathrooms yeah
thanks for visiting at least know what
he saw it yeah like that was the 80s
they were in the 70s but um okay yes you
I was wondering if you were what you
were trying to I think we can also open
up the question
what have you learned about sobriety and
and about what you were after and and
how have you
addressed the cause the effect was the
drinking or the drugs how have you kind
of honed in on the cause of that effect
it's an ongoing thing but I think
probably in my teens some of it was like
gender stuff and and uh just feeling
weird in my body and then I'm sure stuff
at home and well that's a good we were
talking about cognitive dissonance
cognitive like a physical dissonance
yeah massive disparity between how I
feel and how I'm perceived I have no way
to talk about it I mean
yeah oh my God no language around it
right like only recently like I'm 35 I
like just got Top surgery a year ago
like what you know what I mean of course
so that's that's an improvement but it's
still not even it's still not great yeah
you know what I mean but like yeah yeah
it's it in the 90s yeah so then
the 90s was like girl bands and boy
bands like it was very yeah that was its
own kind of 50s yeah it was like we
slipped backwards because the 70s very
androgynous very cool but that's right
um yeah so that and then probably yeah
I'm sure stuff at home and uh and then
wanting to be cool and this all these
older friends and
um and then I think once I had like a
sort of bat damaging relationship with
some older person then you're like then
you're really sad after that so then
it's like a was this the older person
that you dated yeah male do you mind
yeah it was a guy of course
of course you don't mind me asking no I
mean of course it was a guy oh yeah at
the time yeah sure
um and that relationship kind of was an
early wound would you say yeah I think
it definitely was like a loss of
Innocence like yeah yeah yeah it was my
ball it was your ball yeah but then yeah
now how do I I now I I recognize like if
whenever I'm feeling down or bad about
myself I notice little things creeping
back it's like I'm I'm watching a weird
amount of porn like or you know what I
mean or like oh I'm smoking a lot or I'm
whatever it is like all of those
behaviors are the kind they're all the
same yeah the country is yeah yeah or
stand up comedy to a certain extent yeah
I don't mean with you it's clearly not
with you but like some people will
definitely work though like being a
workaholic but I just try to be vigilant
and hey we're recording a podcast on a
Sunday yeah you hear me you got to get
to Ojai man yeah and I'm banking these
because I'm about to go and film
something which is great but yeah what
is it and for all the spiritual growth
that I've endeavored yeah I I I can tell
you from my experience that there have
been major changes in me yes there's
still there's still like a fundamental
dog chasing something in there but then
what happens if that goes away do we do
you just like shrivel up I don't know
like you need a bit of that I agree I
agree it's it's super helpful yeah if
you can have a compulsive attitude
towards work the West will never call
you on it yeah no one will ever say like
take it easy and I'm not trying to be
funny but Kevin Hart Tiffany haddish
these are like icons of that that are
constantly working yeah you know what I
mean because we don't really have that
value that goes like what about Viggo
Mortensen yeah these types that appear
to say no to a lot I hadn't never met
Zach Galifianakis and I met him at Largo
and that's another one oh man so
impressed by that like that's a that's a
hero of mine totally me too like moving
on to Vancouver Island just I always
fantasize about this no identical time
where I'll have four months to just go
to a cottage and but it just never comes
but I'm gonna make it happen May let's
make it happen I feel I don't know I'm
feeling a lot of friendship here yeah me
too I'm feeling a lot
a lot of [__] I was very excited to have
you on but like nobody's talking about
that topic yeah and Zach so I met Zach
when I was like 20 blah blah blah I
don't know but I was young and I was
very hungry yes and two Zach stories one
was there was a great show it doesn't it
was called Whiplash and I was like I'm
gonna put out a record and I'm gonna
record four Whiplash shows because the
set there was 15 minutes so I'm just
gonna record four yeah and marry them
together and have an hour and have the
perfect album yeah and Zach just goes
maybe don't work so hard
like he might as well have said like or
you could eat a baby I'm like like it
didn't make any sense
and then later another exact story I was
also 20s maybe early 30s I was like
um talking to him about
he had he had a farm in North Carolina
he maybe he still does I I I believe so
this is he's always been like he's
always been this way and I go like but
what about like I said something like
and I used to believe this it's like I
gotta know there's a spot somewhere yeah
and he was like yeah I was like that's
life to me like spots yeah and getting
in the mix yeah yeah I hate this but
that's how I felt he was like yeah and
sometimes life is reading a book in a
hammock under an apple tree yeah and he
might as well have said have you
considered the Communist Party yeah like
I just like didn't I understand and now
you're this way I'm this way I told you
I we moved up to oh yeah we're going for
it are you really doable and it's
because of people like Zach and there's
that list is very short yeah very very
short of people that are prioritizing
that balance prioritizing life and then
that and then I bet their comedy will be
great forever because they're they have
stuff to write about and talk about and
they're reading stuff and speed agree
yeah totally because why do some how
many comedians have bits about the
airport is because all we're doing is
traveling yeah yeah yeah and like Zach
is gonna yeah yeah he just made me
realize that he that having him as an
example has changed my life for sure
yeah I gotta read more and go under
apple trees more yeah get me under an
apple tree I was gonna say talking about
compulsive Behavior talking about
balance because we're what time is it
Katie
[__] there's no way we're going to be
able to cover this in a satisfactory way
but we're going to try and we'll try
we'll do our damndest
um burp off Mike
one of the tenants of almost every
spiritual practice whether it be
Buddhism Hinduism mystical Christianity
Judaism all of them are trying to
retrain The Human Experience to lean on
a um you could say a higher power or
some more consistent available
love and I don't mean love and like I
love your work I just mean like a bigger
yes yeah yeah imagine if I meant that
yeah I believe it was done it was I
believe it was Dante who said God is the
love that hung the Stars so it's this
this thing that's like orchestrating and
and maintaining and the the paper
everything's written on I guess you
could say so one of the things as
someone who's uh struggled with
addiction and also is in Show Business
um I'm constantly going back to this
idea that these these other people have
discovered
um the Wellspring inside of them right
this idea that there's there's a
beginning of life and it's looking out
their eyes that's yeah that's my
Fascination there's this quote about God
is a God is a being who's only aware of
his own existence through us like like
yeah and that there's yeah we all have
this still Eternal core within us deep
deep down yeah right that we have to tap
into and tapping into it is to end the
endless hedonic treadmill of I'm only as
happy as the last thing I booked or the
last set I did or the last line that I
did or the last drink that I had all of
these things don't work and I think it's
built into this classroom those things
don't work that is the lesson it's to
leave us unsatisfied and go like well
what does work even like
you know friendships relationships
they're not going to take you all the
way so looking for the thing that does
take you all the way that transcends it
feels like such a losing battle because
the whole culture is designed to make us
anxious and wanting and and feeling
inadequate and it's just all money and
it's just like I really agree it's you
have to fight against so much to I
completely agree but kids are magical
being around kids dogs yeah you know
those they know what's going on there I
completely agree yeah and they take you
out of yourself yeah and that and that
having a baby has been hugely helpful so
I guess the reason I said that was just
to take us into the we only have a
couple minutes here unfortunately I have
to go
um but the god stuff when I saw you do
stand up two you told me to take
reversatrol bitter melon and what was
the third one I do I take it it's
virtual bitter melon and NAC or
something n a NAC or so it was it's some
like amino acid Builder I'm gonna look
it up but you did an Amazon
show like a show for the executives at
Amazon or something I just ended up
sitting next to an Amazon executive at a
dinner after doing an Amazon thing and
and he was like saying he went to Jeff
bezos's Island and that there were these
three supplements that you have to take
for immortality yes and um bitter melon
it was a really compelling argument and
it was yeah bitter I have I take all of
them I think of you every day really
okay yeah I mean I take them too and and
I'm taking Jennifer Aniston's collagen
because I just trust her what is that
what is it called it's collagen powder
and you mix it into drinks and stuff and
I just what is it to leave her um
Youth and youth and like arthritis like
it comes with joints and sort of okay I
I mean I got a smoothie with 30 000
things in it anyway I'll throw I'll
throw some Jennifer Aniston in there
yeah I'm looking it up so people don't
go quick because if I was listening to
this podcast I would be going crazy
I tried NAC
I'm in my order history right now
it's really insane
what I've ordered okay
I think I'm capitalism's wet dream
because I'm just constantly on Amazon
NAC
oh
uh I think this might be it
if it says buy it again
n acetyl cysteine amino acid supplement
is that it maybe maybe but it would show
up it would say buy again all right
go ahead
is it NaCl
[__] [__]
n-r-s NRA join the NRA yeah join the NRA
yeah I know you've been wanting to say
that this whole time trying to find a
way to get that in that message
buy it again see more we're going to
find this okay so tell me about your
current belief system because the other
thing I was going to say when I saw you
you were it's called m n m m n nmn Pro
300. yes I need to that repairs your DNA
or something yeah yeah who knows who
[__] knows who [__] knows but
Bezos I mean that dude I love how the
rich are just desperately trying to go
like live forever I've won yeah and Rich
comedians too yeah yeah yeah you see the
rich comedian you can tell how how well
how how much a comedian makes to do a
theater based on their abs yeah yeah
because when they're all soft and
gelatinous you're like oh he's doing
okay when they start getting hairy and
ripped yeah
it's a lot of bread I don't know that I
want to live forever no you don't my mom
wants to be cryogenically frozen really
she's looking into it
well yeah Ted Williams just uh well
who's Ted Williams who's a baseball
player his head is frozen oh really yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I said why and she
went what could be better than being
I was like wow well according to okay
consider the source but according to
a lot of religions that they're more
mature level yeah
um your mom has no choice their life has
no opposite the opposite of death is
birth life is and all real life is
eternal I love that yeah I love that oh
I just absolutely my source but meaning
I used to have a joke about this I was
like people that think that death is
nothingness I'm like Buddhists would
call that wishful thinking you don't
just get to leave yeah the wheel you're
stuck in desert yeah you do it over and
over until you earn the void but even
the void isn't devoid yeah it's it's uh
the the nothingness like the no
thingness of allness if that makes sense
so your mom will be fine isn't that
great also anyone who's had a near-death
experience or died and come back
describes the same thing which is like
this sort of
sense of benevolent Force and and the
feeling of Oneness and the home yeah
yeah yeah so hopefully it'll be all
right I
well it's funny you ask all of the sages
is there anything to worry about yeah
they would all say no really yeah in my
opinion that's really nice yes the
neurotic narcissistic megalomaniac yeah
Bible
about these people yeah because
again they're taking Duality to
non-duality they're taking yeah this
split reality into Oneness and it just
doesn't translate so they they instead
yank God and make it like us stuck in if
I win you must lose so if we go to
heaven someone must go to hell like it's
it's we have to transcend the
limitations of our realities yeah
exactly so it sounds like uh I'm glad
that we
I guess in talking about this you're
talking about it because it seems like
you're on this page yes what I was
trying to say was when I saw you at
Largo you were taught you had a great
bit about the witness about how who what
what am I and when you were in the
lockdown you were losing your identity
yeah yeah yeah and that was very
spiritual for me as well yeah why don't
we close uh with whatever thoughts you
have on on being or on being our soul
and I'm still here I'm not putting you
on the spot I've just been talking so
much I guess I think
um I I do believe in the illusion of
separateness and and ego and meaning
that separateness is an illusion yeah
yeah I'm like we're all just one giant
like writhing organism like you know
what I mean and uh
I went when I was like 20 I went um to
Nepal to volunteer I was trying to get
clean and I went there my parents paid
for the flight it was great and then I
went up in the mountains and I was like
thinking about how mountains are
tectonic plates going push like that's
crazy they're pushed up against each
other yeah and that you can find like
stuff at the top of Everest from like
the bottom of the ocean and the crazy
stuff but I was like that's the same
Force you know that made me and that's
right I don't know yeah that's right but
I don't know any of this stuff the
Confluence of other things totally yeah
veganism yeah but you're only 30 blah
five yeah
yeah
don't rush it I wanna I Wanna Be
meditating I'll actually take and
Stephanie are doing like Transcendental
Meditation I want to get into all that
but I also kind of love the the
hedonistic world of attachment and shiny
things and stuff like that yeah I I
can't you know I I love that too so well
you have to be somebody before you can
be nobody yeah that's that's a that's a
ROM dust and you can't rush to the end
of the line in fact he would say that a
lot of the bad trips and sort of the
existential crisis of the 60s was that a
lot of people were taking these mind
expanding hallucinate uh nugenics but
they had no basis for them so it's
almost like you have to trust the do the
work it's like you're on this thing
did you know all those cult leaders were
please
um I don't know why that was such a dad
thing like a big well dads just do big
sneezes always yeah and I blow my nose
like I'm haunted yeah so loud
um I didn't know that all like Marilyn
man that meant Marilyn Charles Manson
and all those guys did uh LSD experiment
like we're part of government LSD
experiments I know
and so did Whitey Bulger they gave him
LSD 50 times he's the mobster from
Boston there's yeah like so if you're
not ready for it and you are a
narcissist and you then you could really
well absolutely that's another round
dust thing is if you try to bring your
ego meaning May Martin with you into the
realization of Oneness you'll have a a
psychic break but that's the definition
of paranoia but if you surrender all of
it yeah and go you need to get but our
spiritual job is about me me no I agree
yeah but keep doing it yeah I I actually
I'm surprised there aren't more I don't
need to tell you what to do I'm just
saying like I'm encouraging you to do
what you're already doing and that
um it's a Richard quote we don't come to
God or Truth by doing it right we come
to God by doing it wrong yeah um so this
idea of like the further it's the Hound
of Heaven it's like truth wants to be
discovered it it and there's so much of
them okay I'm gonna read the William
Blake story I'm Googling
what if it's William Blake I forget who
wrote The Hound of Heaven I would re you
know there's one book that I recommend
to anybody which is it's the power of
now it's the Eckhart Tolle book it's a
great audiobook too I've never read it
yeah and it's a classic right it is a
classic and it's very simple and there's
not a lot of like theology or anything
yeah but like you'll you'll get with it
but it has a lot of what you're we're
talking about in your bed it's like who
am I yeah spirituality is is the study
of what doesn't change so when you were
8 or 13 yeah on a cigarette on stage
what was what part didn't change when
you meet you know when I interviewed
Norman Lear and he's in his 90s like
what part of Norman is the same as when
he was nine it's his awareness and
that's that's the part your mom can't
drop your mom will go Ted Williams will
go it doesn't matter where we dethaw
these people yeah they'll go eventually
it doesn't matter if we take the bitter
melon supplement you'll go eventually
and you know
but where are you going where are you
going
yeah
I mean like where could you go yeah yeah
being and there's only now so relax yeah
yeah imagine if you got to go wherever
you believed existed you know like yeah
you're shaping it yeah so if we're
building reality With Our intention or
something then yeah who's to say we're
not also building our well Deepak Chopra
said that when he did his podcast he
goes I believe you get what you expect
cool so if you're like terrified of hell
maybe you go there
but no wouldn't there be part of you
that would be like
it's finally happening would there be
like this weird perverse relief that
you're like yeah yeah and would it be
forever I don't know or would you just
learn that weird lesson I I uh I'm more
in the camp of like
where we come from is where we had it is
yeah and it's and it's benevolent and
yeah actually
my God is so loving it's offensive
meaning it's so it's not just forgiving
it's merciful and it's not it's not
judging or weighing we We Wish It Would
Yes actually there's a great father Greg
Boyle line where it's like God doesn't
even have a plan for you he's too busy
delighting in you to have a plan your
parents have a plan your doctor is a
plan your therapist has a plan God
doesn't have a plan but we want a God to
have a plan to find his parking spots
and stuff so I'm saying this is this
love is so
abstract and and otherworldly that it's
not even would prefer one that squashes
our enemies and helps us you know that's
cool that you it feels like a like a an
actual love not just like a neutrality a
sort of neutral infinite yeah well okay
because I sometimes feel that it's the
latter like neutrality yeah like that
nature is you know we ascribe these
moral things to it but it's actually
just it is you know okay but I don't
with you yeah
but nature is Extreme Duality two trees
look at their Roots they're fighting for
survival it's extreme it's killer be
killed the whole thing we attribute
Beauty to the sun setting and all these
things and that's great I'm not trying
to take that away but really it's it's
all separation and God is beyond that
separation it's beyond this strange
dream we're having yeah and then God is
Not separate to us like it's that's
right yeah yeah yeah it's the animating
principle of you I wasn't expecting this
yeah today but I I put some drugs in
your yeah yeah yeah yeah
we're well you can start kind of
tripping in a good way but yeah it's
always you can have these conversations
if you remember the anchor of like
you're okay it's okay yeah like where
could you go that isn't home because
when you start panicking you just have
to roll with it here's a question I had
for Joe letrulio
yeah I wish we had more time I just I
have to get the car back yeah I'm a
little bit late uh but I have to get the
car back to Val this was awesome this
was so fun I feel like we could do nine
more hours because you have so much
interesting stuff we could do nine more
hours yeah let's talk we'll do it
another time yeah this was awesome
thanks for having me thank you may thank
you um we do have to ask do you know the
time you laughed the hardest in your
life can you think of it you know what
and it's drug related but I know exactly
when tell me it was I was 14 I was with
my best friend Nicole my parents have
gone out for maybe you have it
Nicole you're in the goal yeah and
they'd only gone out for like four hours
my parents but we had a joint and we had
Mead like that honey Mead honey liquor
yeah like which I think was in my house
I don't know why we had you dad's a
centurion yeah yeah exactly and he won a
battle Yeah so they gave him a horn
filled with me yeah which I'd been like
coveting and then we um
and we smoked the joint and it probably
just came from our brains but we were
just like Beyond hysterical we were and
so nothing triggered it but we started
laughing so hard that I thought I was
gonna die like it was real fear of like
what happens if we can never stop like
tears Point like red crawling along the
ground like we were trying to get back
inside and I think it was triggered
because we realized my neighbor had been
on his porch and listening the whole
time or something all right but it was
like looking at each other with real
fear of like what if we can never stop
laughing and like aching like pain and
the neighbor watching this is Mythic and
then getting back inside and just
crawling through my head yeah it was
great Like the Wolf of Wall Street when
he's trying to get in the house yeah all
of the best stories and this is one of
them there have to be the superego there
has to be the the neighbor on their
porch yeah yeah yeah yeah
because otherwise you're just laughing
but you're like this guy's gonna think
we're nuts every time I like make a wish
in a fountain or blow out candles or
something I wish to have like to laugh
the way I did when I was 14 like to have
those like laugh attacks that hurt
because it's so hard to get now no I
know you got the right people around you
you can get there but like that hysteria
of like what is the world who are we
what's happening yeah well I wish that
for you thank you that's incredible yeah
would you say keep it crispy it's how we
close the guest just says keep it crispy
keep it crispy okay the fastest one
um thank you may Martin watch feel good
and and keep an eye out for this new
show I got a special coming out yeah uh
March 28th our stand-up special oh yeah
netflix netflix.com
website yeah yeah thanks everybody
what's it called uh sap sap sap I sort
of regret the title but yeah
because people like me go sap yeah
having to repeat it makes you go it
doesn't matter no I like it thanks all
right here we go here we go
oh yeah
[Music]